when you went back to the philippines um
and you shot the that video was it in
your dad's old neighborhood yeah what
was that like
bro insane bro and you know what's crazy
i actually just see yesterday i i flew
up to the uh to the bay for the for the
day i saw that and i said
i see my grandma she's turning 100 this
week shout out to grandma that's huge
man yeah bro insane she's turning a a
whole honey century bro honey bun wow
she's seen it all well she really does
she was born 1921. she got so much gain
bro i was literally just i was like
imagine how much gain she obtained i
want to bring your grandma on the
podcast i want to talk to somebody who's
that old on my podcast just like yo
you've seen it all you lived through so
much but she lived through so much [ __ ]
and you feel me she's still she's still
mopping you feel me she still go to
church every wednesday and sunday you
know what i'm saying
she's still praying for me every day you
know what i'm saying so she she the one
that's covering me you know what i'm
saying so yeah no but yeah but anyways
but yeah but like that's just insane and
just to be able to like
see like where
you know
my lineage stem from
you know i'm saying like if
one wrong move
or one
step in another direction i could have
been still out there still there still
out there being like one of those kids
like running around the neighborhood
with no shoes on
and you know i'm saying with some like
little sandals on you know i'm saying
but
shout out to pops for bossing up bossed
up oh i heard if you
is it true like if you do drugs out
there they'll like kill your ass oh you
know that they mopping fools
[Music]
but we like anything even if you're
suspected yes you don't even got to be
proven
they'll kill you bro suspected
they'll just smoke you
smoke
[ __ ] get mopped up